[Musique]
donc c'est mon père jean piat man et je
sais pas trop quel âge tu as oublié ma
fille compositrice également chanteuse
claviériste et personnalité hors du
commun mais c'est pas la ville de mon
enfance mais j'y suis déjà depuis
tellement longtemps que c'est un peu
tout comme un finalement c'est une ville
avec un poids affectif très fort parce
que j ai élevé mes enfants et le pecq
c'est une ville traversée par la scène
et par les péniches et pour moi ç'a
toujours été très important c'est la
ville de nos de notre enfance s'est
lassé les racines familiales c'est là où
on a grandi où on a tous grandi ensemble
ça va on y restait 2
je prends les quatre mois peut-être
enfin moi en tout cas j'ai le sac j'ai
vécu près de un petit peu moins de 20
ans c'est l'avis de notre enfance voilà
c'est le berceau on va dire le pecq
c'est notre votre merci je partage pas
la scène je suis invité sur la scène de
mon père ça paraît une petite apparition
que j'appellerais plutôt de locomotive
parce que je pense que je vais être très
grande gentillesse de me prêter sa
réputation pour mon travail c'est
bizarre mais je suis flatté par une part
ma propre fille et s'est pas fait je
suis extrêmement content mais ce n'est
en fin c'était peut-être juste de retour
de chose dans le fond oui c'est vrai ça
juste retour des choses moi j'ai j'ai
l'impression que dans tous mes accord
dans toutes mes mélodies il ya forcément
forcément mais c'est vrai j'ai regardé y
aller j'ai entendu la musique de mes
parents et celle de mon père toute mon
enfance et elle est totalement
omniprésente dans mon travail dans mes
mélodies dans mes choix d'accord dans ma
façon de composer
je crois avoir volé énervement chose il
a jamais eu la délicatesse de ne jamais
me le dire que évidemment il ya des
grilles d'accords qui sont complètement
les successeurs de reconnaître quelques
fois des wii n'est peut-être pas des
thèmes et des
des réflexes musicaux et
et quelque part je suis un double
compositeur parce que j'ai l'impression
que ma fille a su avec le langage de sa
génération transformer mais bob may
balbutiements d'improvisateur au départ
c'est un peu une histoire de famille je
ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai voulu emmener
mes enfants là bas parce que enfants
j'ai rêvé d'aller là bas comme beaucoup
de petits français des années 50 avant
de réfléchir à comment l'histoire de la
mairie s'inscrivait dans l'histoire
mondiale
mais cette perception naïve que j'avais
ce besoin de liberté passer par la
mairie mais aussi new york ces espèces
de deal qui flotte un peu dans l'océan
il y avait un côté aventure maritime et
familiale et pour moi je sais tu es un
des plus beaux voyages de ma vie parce
que j'ai prouvé avec mes enfants cette
sensation de liberté à c'est un indice
id ne sais pas pourquoi mais je me suis
sentie transporter le mot est important
parce que transporte sur moi c'est une
chose importante qui fait rêver
donc notre amérique merci
[Musique]
l'amérique l'amérique
voilà chanter comme ça a raconté comme
ça l'amérique c'est une telle aventure
c'est la liberté c'est les grands
espaces c'est les gratte ciel qui vont
aller toucher les dieux les cieux c'est
la folie des grandeurs voilà c'est
l'amérique donc donc du coup ouais ça me
semblait bien d'ouvrir d'ouvrir cette
soirée-là sur quelque chose qui me fait
un peu un clin d'oeil à une ont eu la
vision de l'amérique une vision un peu
naïve et surtout ça peut le dépasser
mais surtout mais en tout cas voilà se
trouve de la folie des grandeurs que cet
impôt d'ouvrir là dessus
[Musique]
c'est un orchestre qui s'est
professionnalisé assez naturellement
parce que ce sont tous des gens jeunes
d'abord qui vit qui sont en plus des
têtes comme on dit ils viennent tous
deux ils sont tous fait des études
absolument prodigieux c'est plutôt les
scientifiques d'ailleurs je dirais d'une
façon un petit peu
médiatique c'est un peu la star ac de la
musique classique sont très jeunes etc
des étoiles montantes
[Musique]
g